INSTRUCTOR: Hi there,
2,100 students.
In this video, we are going to
jump into lists and for loops
in Python, lists and for
loops are super helpful,
and they enable us to be able to
loop through a series of items
and perform something on
those series of items.
So often happens a lot when
we are bringing in data,
say, from an Excel
spreadsheet, or in our sense,
we're going to loop
through our database output
based upon a query
that we write.
The Python runs for us.
But before we get to that
point, let's discuss lists
and for loops.
Now we talk about when
we think about lists--
we're going to come back
to that in a second.
But lists assign a
variable a set of elements.
This can be strings,
floats, integers, et cetera.
This is one way we
can store and access
data in our Python programs.
So we can edit lists.
We can use append, slice and
replace, but we can't replace,
but we can edit lists.
As a part of lists.
We can also utilize
index values which
allow us to say, identify
a certain value in a list
and print that value.
So if I say only print the first
value in a list, I can go--
I can use index
values to do that.
So that's just an aside.
We're going to loop back
around to index values.
But let's talk about lists
here for just a little bit.
So I'm going to jump
into my Colab notebook.
So please do so as well.
I've already copied mine to
drive so I can save my edits.
We're going to these are
just fun programs here today.
We're going to get into
more business context,
but we're going to
write a program that
fulfills these requirements.
Create a list called
fave activities.
Then we're going to include four
values in this list that include
your favorite activities.
Print the values in the list at
the 0 and first index values.
So let's do this.
So I'm going to create this list
I'm going to say fave activity.
So I'm declaring a variable.
Fave activities equal to,
and then I start and end this
with square brackets.
This right now is
in creating a list.
A list begins and ends
with square brackets.
So right now I have
created an empty list.
So if I was to run
this, I've created
a list named fave activities
and that list is empty.
If I was to highlight
over fave activities,
you will notice
that it is a list,
but there are 0 items
associated with that list.
So now let's go ahead and add
in some values to this list.
We separate the values
within our list with commas.
So if I say are my favorite
activities currently obsessed
with pickleball.
All right.
Obsessed with pickleball.
Don't even get me started.
Let's see.
I also I love to ride my bike.
[LAUGHS] Oh, my gosh,
I love it so much.
Brian that helps me with all
my recordings, and Trent.
Ryan just peered
through the window
when I mentioned pickleball.
I am obsessed.
They know it.
All right.
Pickleball, that's so fun.
Pickleball, biking,
let's see what else?
Right now, I mean, I don't
know if I would love to write,
but I do a lot of writing
and I kind of enjoy it.
I'm working on my
PhD, so there's that.
And I also love snowboarding.
All right.
So let's just say that for now.
Also, love getting
a nice diet coke.
So anyway I could add a
lot of favorite activities.
But let's go-- so we're
going to create this list.
Let's go ahead.
And we included four values.
So let's press Play.
And you'll notice here when I
highlight over fave activities,
the duration of this program,
fave activities is a list
and it contains four
items pickleball biking
riding and snowboarding.
Now, I want to print the
values in the list at the 0
and first index values.
All right.
So let's go ahead and do this.
So I'm going to say Print.
Now, if I just say print fave
activities and I run this,
you're going to notice
that it outputs to me all
of the values in my list.
But I said here, I want to
print the values at the 0
and first index value.
Zero index value, that
doesn't make any sense.
Well, if I come back
here to my PowerPoint,
you'll notice that Python
starts counting with zero.
So let's check this out.
So Python actually labels
pickleball as the 0 index value.
The value at the 0 index value
of the fave activities list.
Biking is at the first index
value, riding is at the second,
and so forth.
So if I was to print fave
activities at the 0 index value
and I run this, then
I notice that it only
prints out to me pickleball.
So I want to print the
values in the list at the 0
and first index values.
So if I say fave
activity zero, then it's
only going to print
to me pickleball.
That's at the 0 index value.
But I want to print the
0 and first index value.
So I want to say
pickleball and biking.
So I'm going to say start
printing at the value of 0 index
value and print up until but
not including the second index
value.
Now, that's a little
confusing, but when I run this,
you'll notice that pickleball
and biking outputs to me,
it doesn't include writing.
So 0 index values pickleball,
first index value is biking,
second index value is writing.
And I'm only supposed to print
the values of the list of 0
and first index values.
But you'll notice that I
put 0 index value start
printing right up until but
not including the second index
value.
So this second-- so when I
say 0 colon and then a value,
this means print up until
but not including that value.
So you can play
around with this.
If I actually wanted
to say, you know what,
print pickleball,
biking, and riding to me,
then I want to print starting
at 0 and print up until
but not including that
third index value,
which would be snowboarding.
So now I run this.
We can see here that we have
those three values outputting
to me.
So just keep that in mind.
Play around with index values.
They help us identify a specific
part in this case of lists.
We can also do the same
thing with strings.
All right so same
as program one.
But now I want to add the
word write Python code
to the end of the list.
It's one of your
favorite activities.
All right.
So now change the value of
the element in the third index
position to be equal to
watch movies and then output
all elements in
the list starting
with the one in the
third index position.
All right.
So we got a couple of
things we want to do here.
So first off, add
value to the list.
So I'm going to say, all right.
And I have to have
ran the code block
up above, so I know
that I can refer
to 5 activities throughout the
rest of my Jupyter Notebook
here.
So I want to say
five activities.
So I'm going to declare that.
Again, I'm going to pull
that list name down,
and I want to say
fave activities dot
append right Python code.
So now I'm appending the
value of fave activities.
I'm appending the value
of write Python code
to my list fave activities.
And I'm going to
print fave activities.
So now let's run
this, and I see--
Oh great.
I have my list, my four
favorite activities,
and I've appended write Python
code to the end of that list.
So we can add values to lists
using this append method.
Here again, this appends
a write Python code
to the end of the list.
Then I'm going to
change the value
of the element in the
third index position
to be equal to watch movies.
Now, watching movies is not
one of my favorite activities,
but if it is for you, we're
going to go ahead and add it.
So let's go ahead and
say, all right fave.
Let's see, change the value
of the third index value
to be watched movies.
All right.
So now let's identify what is
in my third index position.
So let's see here.
Let's see 0 would be
pickleball, one would be biking,
two would be riding right.
Python starts counting at 0.
So 0 pickleball, one
biking, two riding.
And the third index
position is snowboarding.
So I actually want to change
snowboarding to be watch movies.
So you're going to
say fave activities.
And then I want to narrow
in on that one value.
So I'm going to use a third
index value snowboarding
and set it equal
to watch movies.
Now, when I run this and I
press let's print this here.
Let's print fave activities.
Oh, activities.
You'll notice up here
I have an air there.
OK activities.
Oh, not face, fave.
All right, there we go.
Now go ahead and run this.
And I have pickleball,
biking, riding.
Here is my write Python code.
This is my first
print statement.
And my second print statement.
You'll notice that snowboarding
is now changed to watch movies.
All right awesome.
Now, I want to
output all elements
of the list starting with
the one and the third index
position.
So I want to output
everything starting
with the one in the third index
position, which is watch movies.
So output everything starting
with the third index position.
So now I say print
fave activities
and I want to start
printing with the value
in the third index position
and just print everything
after that.
So what I do now is I can
actually just leave the code--
the part after the colon empty
within my square brackets.
So start printing at
that third index position
and keep printing till the end.
So now I run this and I
have watch movies, which
is my third index position.
Write Python code and
write Python code.
Oh, it's adding it every time.
[LAUGHS] All right.
So what's going on here?
Well, because I've ran
this program three times,
it's added write Python code
three times to my program.
We won't worry too
much about that,
but just keep that in mind
that's what's happening here.
So I really should actually
come up here, do a new code box,
and change this append
to be in its own code box
so I only run it one time.
So let's go ahead and
rerun this program.
I'm going to come up here
create my fave activities again.
So I've recreated
that variable that I'm
going to append write
Python code to it.
Then I'm going to change
the values to watch movies.
And now I get watch movies and
write Python code as my value
that's in the third
index position
and that prints
until the very end.
All right.
So again, because I kept running
the same program code of text
that had the append in it,
it added write Python code
three times.
But this is correct.
I'm outputting everything that
starts with the third index
position, which is watch movies
until the end of the list
or until the end of the list.
So I can see here that
I've watched movies
and write Python code
outputting to me.
All right.
Awesome.
Now, I want to
write a program that
fulfills these requirements.
I want to create a
list called Candy
that consists of the names of
your five favorite candy bars.
Then use a for loop to print
out the names of the five,
one at a time, each
on a separate line.
So let's go ahead and do this.
I'm going to say, my
list is called Candy.
And right now I'm just--
this is an empty list.
If I was to run this is going
to create an empty list.
My favorite candy currently
loving Almond Joys.
So good.
Love a KitKat.
Twix, also awesome.
[LAUGHS] All right, let's see
five of my favorite candy bars.
Butterfingers are good.
Let's see what else is good.
Oh, well, my maiden name is
Reese, so I'll say Reese's.
All right.
So we'll just put it like that.
Now I want to create this--
so I've created this list.
And then I want
to use a for loop
to print out the names of
the five, one at a time,
each on a separate line.
So right now, if I was
just to say print candy,
meaning print all the
values from my list candy,
it prints out to me Almond Joys,
KitKat, Twix, Butterfinger,
Reese's all on the same line.
And then I write in this list
format, which isn't great.
So instead, I want to say
for something in list,
print this list.
All right.
Let's take a look.
What does this mean.
So I'm going to come over
here and look at for loops.
So for statement tells Python
to assign the variable x,
see here below, to be equal to
the next element in the list.
Customers.
Then it carries out the
command and the indented block
below for loop.
It will keep doing this
sequentially, assigning elements
in customers to
be the variable x
so long as there are
elements left in customers.
So for example, here's
my customers list.
I have Sam, Elizabeth, and John.
There's three
elements in this list
and I say for x in customers.
So basically declaring
I'm basically
having this random
variable here represent
the value of the
first value here
0 index value
though of customers
and I say for x and
customers print x.
Sam is initially signed
to be the value of x
And then I print Sam.
OK, then the next
time through the loop
it says Oh, x is now equal to
Elizabeth and I print Elizabeth.
Next time through the loop it
goes, is there another value?
And yes, there is John.
So I assign John to be the value
of x and then I print John.
So I print Sam, print
Elizabeth, and print John.
Because x is equal to
Sam, first time through,
x is then equal to Elizabeth,
and then x is equal to John.
And I print that.
So just keep that in mind.
That's what I'm doing.
I'm looping through that list.
And for every value in this list
I'm doing whatever is indented
and beneath that for loop.
All right.
So let's come back here and
I'm going to say for x in candy
so I can declare doesn't have
to be x, I could say for y
for pickleball and candy.
It doesn't matter, I
just have this variable
that I am using for the purposes
of iterating through this list.
So I say for x in candy print x.
Now I run this and let's get rid
of this upper print statement
so It doesn't confuse us.
So now for loop prints every
one of my values in my list
candy, each on a separate line.
So it's looping through.
It's saying for x
in candy, meaning
assign the value Almond Joys
to be equal to x, then print x.
Then assign the value of
KitKat to be equal to x, then
print x and it
prints KitKat Then
assign the value, right
every time through that list
until at the end, right.
My program is done because
I've ran out of values.
It prints Reese's.
There's nothing else
coming after that.
So my program just ends.
Now, same as above,
same as program 3,
but using a counter variable,
number each of the names when
it gets printed out,
i.e. list the first
as number one, then number two.
So let's do the same thing here.
And we're going to again
just copy my program down.
And I'm going to say
now I want to count
every time through this
variable or through this list.
So I'm going to
create my counter
and say counter equal to 0.
And once I've established
that counter is equal to 0,
then every time
through my list I
want to increase the
value of counter by one.
So I'm going to say
all right once I
am-- so for x in candy I want
to increase the counter by one.
And then I want to print
the value of counter
and then the value of x.
So I'm separating these
two values by a comma
and now I ran it.
And it says one, Almond Joys,
two, KitKat, three, Twix.
So what's happening here is this
counter variable the first time
through the value.
So when I first established
counter it's equal to 0.
Then I increase the
value of counter
by one, when I'm looping through
the first item in the list,
which is Almond Joy.
Then I print the value of
counter, which at that point
is then one because I've
increased the value by 1,
and then I print the value
of Almond Joy after it.
Then I do the same
thing I come up.
Is there another
value in that list?
There sure is, KitKat.
I assign KitKat
to the value of x.
I increase the counter by one.
So now the counter is equal to
2, and the value of x prints
again, which is KitKat.
And I keep on coming down here.
So there you go.
There is our program
number four where
I'm using a counter variable.
Now, it says here that I
should have one period.
Almond joy.
So let's go ahead and do that.
I'm going to use f-strings now.
I'm going to say f-strings.
Take the value from the variable
counter, place a one after it,
and then place the value
from the variable x.
Now, we'll include a quotation
mark after and there we go.
And our print statement.
Oh, no.
Oh, I just wanted that period.
I just want the
value from counter.
There we go.
Counter, period,
the value from x.
And there we have it.
So there you go.
There's question number
four or program number four.
Hopefully, this has been helpful
for you to learn about lists.
Learn how we can use for
loops to loop through lists.
And we're really going
to use this a lot
when we get into bringing
SQL into our Python programs.
Thanks, everybody.
Have a great rest of your day.
Take care.